es ist dann absolut trauriger wendepunkt
laut einer aktuellen studie überwiegt
alles künstlich auf unserer erde
die gesamtheit des lebens auf unserem
heimatplaneten
die rede ist von plastikflaschen
computern kleidern wolkenkratzern und
und das ist mehr als die gesamte
biomasse alle pflanzen und tiere auf
unserem planeten befinden wir uns also
schon längst im zeitalter des menschen
im sogenannten anthropozän und gefährden
wir mit unserem wirken den fortbestand
der menschlichen zivilisation krieg zum
science news gibt's drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los ganz herzlich
willkommen das sind wirklich
erschreckende zahlen die die aktuelle
studie eines forschungsteams vom
weizmann institute of science in israel
nun enthüllt demnach gibt es
mittlerweile mehr menschen gemacht das
material als biomasse auf unserer erde
rund achtung 1,1 millionen tonnen wiegen
alle technologien infrastrukturen und
bauwerke die von menschenhand geschaffen
wurden und damit wird das trockengewicht
aller natürlichen und lebenden
komponenten auf unserem heimatplaneten
übertroffen
die fachleute sprechen von zitat
schockierenden zahlen und es gibt ein
weiteres erschreckendes ergebnis dass
die aktuelle studie aus israel offenbart
ist das ein entscheidender wendepunkt in
der menschheitsgeschichte
was bedeuten diese ergebnisse für die
gesamtbilanz der erde und ist diese
überhaupt noch von natur und lebewesen
geprägt und was passiert wenn sich
dieser trend in den kommenden jahren so
fortsetzt genau diese fragen werden wir
in diesem video beantworten die aktuelle
studie die ihnen der renommierten
wissenschaftszeitschrift nature
erschienen ist verdeutlicht jedenfalls
mit aller wucht welche fatalen
auswirkungen wir menschen auf unseren
heimatplaneten haben es herrscht ein
krasses ungleichgewicht zum einen die
gesamtmasse aller lebensformen auf der
erde diese hat sich in den vergangenen
jahren kaum verändert und liegt bei etwa
1,1 millionen tonnen
90 prozent davon machen die weltweite
vegetation und vor allem wälder aus der
rest sind pilze bakterien und protesten
also beispielsweise algen und eben auch
die tiere wozu in dieser studie auch die
menschliche bevölkerung gezählt wurden
herauskommt wir menschen fallen hierbei
im wahrsten sinne des wortes nicht ins
gewicht denn wir tragen wir etwa 0,0
zu diesem trockengewicht aller lebenden
biomasse bei wichtig hierbei in der
aktuellen studie geht es um das
trockengewicht würde man den
wassergehalt der biomasse dazurechnen
käme man nach analyse der vorstände auf
gute 2 millionen tonnen
wichtig hierbei aber vor allem die
diskrepanz des wachstums im vergleich zu
der sogenannten anthropogenen masse
künstlicher materialien denn diese ist
in den vergangenen jahren alles andere
als gleich geblieben die masse dieses
menschengemachten materials wächst
exponentiell
gemeint sind damit beispielsweise alle
technologien bauwerke und
infrastrukturen aber auch kleidung
plastikflaschen und fußwege in der
aktuellen studie aus israel wurden alle
menschengemachten materialien aus stein
metall holz und sieht ethischen stoffen
die plastik mitgezählt die analyse aus
israel deckt auf dass die sogenannte
anthropogene masse derzeit in etwa der
biomasse dieser erde entspricht doch
noch in diesem jahr also 2020 könnte sie
diese sogar übersteigen fest steht wir
menschen haben die erde so verändert wie
bislang kein anderes lebewesen vor uns
wir menschen haben sogar ganz neue
substanzklasse geschaffen gemeint sind
zum beispiel kunststoffe und andere
synthetische materialien viele
landschaften sind von siedlungen
bauwerken und straßen durchzogen in
megacities wie shanghai beispielsweise
schrumpft die pflanzendecke zusammen zu
sehen sind nur noch wolkenkratzer beton
und asphalt
dieser trend hat nach ansicht der
fachleute bereits vor langer zeit seinen
anfang genommen und zwar mit dem
aufkommen von viehzucht und ackerbau die
jäger und sammler kulturen wurden vor
etwa 12.000 jahren sesshaft die
landwirtschaft und entwaldung nahm zu
und so haben die menschen dafür gesorgt
dass sich die weltweite pflanzliche
biomasse halbiert hat von ursprünglich
etwa zwei millionen tonnen auf den
aktuellen wert von rund einer million
tonnen also nur noch mal zur erinnerung
auch wenn das 12.000 jahre her ist
ursache dafür sind ackerbau und
viehzucht nur weil etwas vor tausenden
von jahren begründet wurde
heißt das noch lange nicht dass es gut
ist und in unsere zeit passt auf uralte
traditionen müssen immer wieder
dahingehend überprüft werden ob sie noch
funktionieren bei der anthropogenen
masse dagegen also der menschen gemacht
masse gab es in den vergangenen 100
jahren einen exponentiellen anstieg laut
der aktuellen studie hat sich das
gesamtgewicht dieser struktur und alle
20 jahre
verdoppelt natur und menschenwerk sind
also zunehmend aus dem gleichgewicht
geraten nach ansicht des israelischen
forschungsteams hat die wachsende
produktion und anhäufung von objekten zu
zitat einer verschiebung des
gleichgewichts zwischen der leben und
der von menschen geschaffenen masse
geführt wir befinden uns genau an einem
kreuzungspunkt um das jahr 2020 wird die
akte pro gene masse die gesamte weltweit
lebende biomasse übertreffen methodisch
gegen die fachleute vom weizmann
institut für wissenschaften in israel so
vor dass sie zahlreiche studien zu
dieser thematik genauer ins visier nahm
damit gelang es ihnen veränderungen bei
der globalen biomasse und der
anthropogenen masse zu analysieren und
deren entwicklung von 1900 bis jetzt
gegenüber zu stellen und zu vergleichen
so wurde das rasante wachstum der masse
an menschen gemachte material deutlich
ein krasser wendepunkt der nun also
erreicht wurde auf unserer erde gibt es
mehr maschinen straßen und bauwerke als
bäume kräuter und büsche
dazu heißt es in der studie allein die
globale masse des produzierten plastiks
ist größer als die aller land und
wassertiere zusammen der aktuellen
analyse zufolge sind es vor allem
bauwerke und straßen in den größten teil
ausmachen
bei den materialien dominieren beton und
gemischte baumaterialien wie
beispielsweise schotter das ganze ausmaß
wird vor allem durch die folgende
aussage deutlich die rein rechnerisch zu
betrachten ist demnach produziert jeder
mensch pro woche so viel weiteres
anthropogene material wie er selbst
wiegt das forschungsteam aus israel
zeigt sich extrem besorgt über diese
ergebnisse so auch der wissenschafter
ron milo seiner ansicht nach befindet
sich die erde in einem materiellen
wandel der zitat nicht nur einmal im
leben sondern nur einmal in einem
zeitalter geschieht demnach könnten
diese ein argument dafür sein dass der
erde nun in das so genannte anthropozän
eingetreten ist gemeint ist damit eine
neue geologische epoche in der wir
menschen die dominante kraft auf dem
planeten sind nach ansicht der fachleute
sei dieser trend hin zu menschen
gemachten material nicht mehr
aufzuhalten so schreibt das
forschungsteam als fazit wenn der
aktuelle trend anhält könnte die
anthropogene masse einschließlich der
abfälle das trockengewicht der globalen
biomasse bis zum jahr 2040 um das
dreifache übertraf
die studie liefert also ein weiteres
symbolisches merkmal das anthropozän die
zunehmende dominanz des menschen auf der
erde ein neues kapitel in der
erdgeschichte zu dem sich auch schon
viele andere forschende weltweit
geäußert haben sie sprechen von einem
menschen gemachten zeitalter in dem
nicht mehr die natur die erde gestaltet
sondern die menschen demnach ist der
homo sapiens zu einem der wichtigsten
einflussfaktoren auf die prozesse im
erdsystem geworden menschen beeinflussen
das klima sie verändern sowohl
biologische als auch chemische
kreisläufe und menschen bauen ganze
ökosysteme und landschaften um der us
umweltwissenschaftler rtl ist überzeugt
davon dass mittlerweile mindestens 75
prozent der bewohnbaren erdoberfläche
von den menschen über formte natur sind
seine bezeichnung dafür an throm
abgeleitet von dem begriff biome aus den
biowissenschaften mit dem fachleute die
grundeinheit der großen ökologischen
systemen unbestritten ist also dass der
mensch einen prägenden einfluss auf die
erde hat dennoch wird der begriff des
anthropozän heißt diskutiert die große
frage hierbei zeigt sich unser verhalten
und unser wirken tatsächlich in den
erdschichten und das auf
charakteristische art und weise würden
die spuren unserer eingriffe auch noch
in tausenden oder millionen jahren
erhalten bleiben denn nur in diesem fall
wollten biologinnen und biologen
tatsächlich eine neue epoche nach
unserer spezies benennen auch die frage
nach einem möglichen anfang dieser neuen
epoche wird noch diskutiert eine sache
wird bei dieser diskussion aber mehr als
deutlich es ist die zeit eines
gesellschaftlichen umdenkens wir müssen
verstehen welchen einfluss mehr auf die
erde haben und somit auch erkennen
welche folgen unser handeln für kommende
generationen haben wird einige
veränderungen die wir als spezies zu
verantworten haben könnten
möglicherweise sogar den fortbestand der
menschlichen zivilisation gefährden dazu
von milo vom weizmann-institut unsere
studie zeigt wie viel größer als unsere
eigentliche schuhgröße unser globaler
fußabdruck ist wir hoffen dass wir als
spezies verantwortung übernehmen können
wenn wir diese ziemlich schockierenden
zahlen vor augen haben wir brauchen
keine landwirtschaft alternative
anbaumethoden der zukunft in der edition
zukunft rowohlt also anklicken dieses
video anschauen und diesen kanal hier
klickst heinz im future abonnieren bis
dann
bleibt dran